so how does it feel being at the Grammys
today it feels good I just came from
Vegas I don't had a show last night so
it was a hectic morning but then it's
arrived and it's raining like crazy like
a tsunami out there thank you
no but they were scrubbing like the
carpet yeah up there so like he's like
oh they're like pushing the water out on
anybody who's stepping in say it like
it's like being by the beach actually
there's never a good sign when they have
to spool out there the show tonight
there's so many amazing performances
coming up any one that you're looking
forward to seeing who's playing okay I
want that let's see that yeah Miley's
doing that I'm excited for that Camila
Cabello is gonna play do leave miss me
play one kiss yeah it's gonna be fun
good vibes and then how do you celebrate
when the night is over have a party
tonight big one yeah it's it's private
it's up in the hills big dance floor
all the dance nominees are all gonna
play together and have a big party yeah
like you have this is the biggest
weekend of the year for you guys I mean
the weekend is great because you have
the Grammy Award ceremony but you have
so many great events where a lot of
songwriters and musicians and label
people all meet and have fun together
and you can actually network sounds
corny but you can meet people and talk
about what you're doing and and not be
like you know pushy and it's kind of a
there's a vibe do you meet people you
meet people you would never meet you
know normally and you know a lot of
collaborations can come of like a
weekend like this do you have anything
coming up that you can tease that's
already in North um you know we had we
were nominated for Silk City tonight and
we have a whole album we're finishing up
LSD with SIA just like a project hai
with SIA and then um just I mean I'm
always making music so if I have a
record come out next week I might put a
record out tonight after the show now
you have done so many collaborations I
couldn't even begin to name them all but
who is left on your bucket list to
collaborate with and give them a plea
right to camera
I was like Clive Davis last night I saw
Nancy Pelosi I was trying to meet her
and get a picture so in Barbra
Streisand's the next hour so Nancy
Pelosi and Barbra Streisand trying to
work with them why should they work with
you I just got the my finger on the
pulse man I'm out there I'm ready to
work
hit me up
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]